how old were you when you arrived in Los
Angeles ooh that's a good one I was what
hit song was out well that's a good one
I remember aleeah's um are you that
somebody okay I remember that being on
listen moving to LA was like a serious
culture shot okay cuz you know I came
from Atlanta Augusta Ga and I had lived
there for years and then you know I had
this R&B artist who flew me out
it was around Thanksgiving time and
we're working on his second album which
never saw the light of day unfortunately
but I remember going down on the 101
because the 101 always freaked me out it
was just like this is you know I'm not
used to these type of freeways and I
remember are you that somebody by
Aaliyah being on because I thought it
was so odd to hear a baby in it and in
this song I was like Tim man is crazy
he's got this little baby going in but
this is a dope song so yeah whatever
year that that was I guess that was 98
I'm I had been what is this that was
that was 20 years ago I probably was I
was 28 yeah yeah 28 27 28 okay what were
your expectations when you think back to
driving down that 101 by the way the 101
scares me too so I can see why but it's
also invigorating at night it's so
beautiful yeah there's right there's a
sense of possibility like wow this is
Los Angeles and I'm here but still it is
scary but what were your expectations at
that time I thought in a year's time I
was gonna have probably five hit records
on a radio I was gonna win a not a not
an Oscar a Grammy and I would be able to
buy my mom a house
and yeah that's that was a rough time
because for how many years that I have
been working on doing music and having
the success that I did have living in
Georgia and having my songs on the radio
and stuff when I moved to LA that didn't
happen and it was just a rough time I
mean I was living with the artists
family I didn't have my own place and it
was hard finding my space in that
production company and seeing I was
seeing where things were gonna be at
that time so what you're asking on one
hand I had expectations on where I
wanted it to go but I was also seeing
where it wasn't gonna go and that's
tough
especially when you're working with
someone so talented because you're
saying I see where you're headed and
it's not good and if that's where you're
headed what's gonna happen to me
everything happens for a reason you know
I look back at my music career and I say
man you know as much I still love music
I mean if I had an opportunity I
probably would work with somebody and
come out with an amazing record but I
didn't get the love that I get in film I
didn't get that love in music and so you
have to go with where the love is
reciprocated as much as I love music it
wasn't loving me as much as I loved film
it loves me and that to me is you know
it's like any relationship you don't
mean it can't be one-sided so my
expectations were I I you know I I
assumed that I would have at least five
songs on the radio I was that good of a
music producer and a songwriter but it
wasn't meant to be and I had to accept
that and I had to accept that and in
making that transition helped me to move
into film easier we talked about earlier
flexibility and it goes back to sort of
Darwinism to talks about you know the
species that survives are the ones that
can adapt so you're talking about you
saw even though you loved music it was
everything
you wanted to be what was that moment
like when you realized I mean how did
you even see that how did you see as
much as I love this this is me it's not
gonna happen
oh I'm probably speaking the tale of
many people who got to that point and
quit the industry rather than making the
adjustment I think that's what happens I
think there's a point where everyone
gets to in their life where they go okay
listen you know I'm not receiving it
because it's really all about love it
really is all we're looking for is human
beings is for love we're all looking for
it some of us we find it and
entertainment some of us we find it from
our children we find it from the spouse
that we wit we find it from our family
we find it from God we find from our
religion we find it the way that we need
to find it and when it's not
reciprocated it's a very powerful and
painful thing it was a cathartic moment
for me it was tough I remember being on
my knees and just crying and saying God
why don't you bring me out here if this
is not gonna happen like you know what
do i do do I go back to you know to
Augusta do I you know go to New York
what do I do it's not happening I've
been struggling you know I was a
personal trainer working at a gym but I
did so many different jobs but I think
when you listen to that inner voice you
know Oprah calls it the aha moment
I just believe it's just an epiphany
when you wake up and you go you know
what maybe that's just not the way it's
supposed to happen and if you let go
because sometimes God is say be still
and know that I am God and I said oh
okay what does that mean what is that
level of faith of understanding that if
you wake up in the morning that you're
breathing that you're eating that you
have your capacity of your limbs and
you're still moving forward you have a
roof over your head you have food to eat
you have clothes on your back he's
giving you everything that you need so
you just have to make that adjustment
and the adjustment for me was okay
listen music is not the way but getting
into film years later needing to work on
the music which moves any film I had all
of that experience
and I said wait a minute that's what
that was for so I snatched that big
pearl not took it and put it into my
collection of jewels and now I realized
okay all of those years of doing that no
different than me being mugged or going
through the violence that I went through
in Brooklyn as a kid which got me into
the martial arts all of those years of
music and stuff helps me as a film
director it helps me to teach my actors
because they don't know 80s music or 70s
music or 60s and 50s and 40s and 30s and
20s I know all of that stuff because I
spent so many years in music so now when
I'm teaching them something about acting
I got a little extra resource that I can
give them through lyrics that they've
never heard because all they listened to
his current music man how powerful is
that when I'm telling them hey listen to
Bruce Springsteen and he was saying this
in this song how close is that or listen
to Richard mark when he's talking about
it don't mean nothing and this is
attributing to your acting career your
singing career your dance career and
they're going wow this is amazing stuff
they've never heard these songs
you